[Musique]
elle existe depuis plus de 20 ans
l'harmonie de saint quentin en yvelines
se produira au festin money ce week end
du 14 et 15 mai pour cette deuxième
édition une dizaine de concerts sont
prévus à montigny le bretonneux
au départ les membres de l'ensemble de
sky n'étaient que 12 c'était il ya plus
de vingt ans aujourd'hui saxophoniste
flûtiste clarinettiste ils sont près de
quarante musiciens à faire partie de
l'harmonie chacun a son rôle quand on a
les instruments qui sont dans les graves
c'est d'apporter la stabilité de
l'orchestré de donner le tempo de
permettre de liquider et puis tu en
entends l'instrument il est soliste
effectivement selon les passagers les
compositions l'ensemble se réunit deux
heures tous les jeudis des rendez vous
collectif important pour caler les
musiques ont travaillé chacun chez soi
et donc le rythme tout ça c'est se fait
au rythme particulier qui nous est
propre et qui nous permet de jouer
facilement mais quand on est dans
l'ensemble faut poursuivre notre chef et
là ça se complique donc corps d'où
l'intérêt de faire les répétitions des
répétitions à quelques heures du début
du festival les membres de l'harmonie
peaufiner les derniers détails
merci c'est à dire que la falaise
février et mis à la mesure 3 par exemple
je fais un peu plus on est tous réunis
et donc on va c'est un peu une générale
on va répéter tous les morceaux dans
l'ordre ma le détail si on fait aussi
l'enchaînement on fait aussi ce qu'on
appelle une générale donc là c'est le
cas
et on essaye de travailler les nuances
et puis la justesse aussi il ya des
hauts et des bas mais ce qui compte
c'est que on progresse tous ensemble
vers plus de qualité justement pour le
festival le répertoire sera varié du
jazz au classique en passant par la
variété mais aussi des musiques de films
en tout cas on est sur le chemin avec
les trains le train train quotidien qui
va changer quoi on est dedans dans le
jacobites express cède à petite synthe
plaisir voilà rendez vous samedi 14 mai
à la salle du manet de montigny le
bretonneux pour découvrir ce répertoire
[Musique]